hi this is Brandon roar with some
thoughts on data scientist archetypes in
other words what kind of data scientists
do you want to be when you first come to
the field of data science even if you've
been in it for a while you can be easily
overwhelmed by the number of tools and
the vast range of skills required blog
posts about what it takes to become a
data scientist devolving to laundry list
of skills that you don't have yet and
tools you haven't learned yet this is
discouraging and it's counterproductive
my goal here is to give you a map for
navigating the sprawling terrain of data
science is to help you prioritize what
you want to learn and what you want to
do so that you don't feel lost these
ideas are not mine alone they're based
on a series of interviews with the data
scientists listed here who are from
several different companies as well as
contributors from academic data science
programs the underlying ideas are
captured in a public document offered as
a resource to academic data science
programs from industry data scientists
an attempt at a virtual industry
advisory committee any insights you get
from this material that I'm presenting
here I credit to this group but any
errors or inaccuracies are probably due
to me alone
overall this is a compilation of a lot
of people's ideas who have spent time
thinking deeply about it
the real reason data science feels so
big is because it's no longer a single
field there are actually three separate
pillars there's data analysis which is
taking raw information and turning it
into knowledge that can be acted on or
that can drive a decision there's data
modeling using the data that we have to
estimate the data that we wish we had
and then there's data engineering which
is taking these analysis and modeling
activities and making everything work
faster more robustly and on larger
quantities of data so these three areas
are all distinct they all require
different skills and different sets of
tools if you feel overwhelmed when you
approach data science it's because
you're actually approaching three
different fields at the same time now
let's dive a little deeper into each one
of these there are several aspects of
data analysis the process of taking data
and turning it into into information
that we can use to make a decision
there is domain knowledge this is the
ability to translate a business need or
a practical concern to a question it
involves making trade-offs between how
accurate the answer should be and how
much time and money you want to spend
finding it
domain knowledge is also absolutely
necessary for interpreting the data for
understanding not just the numbers and
labels presented but what they reflect
in the real world and what we can
realistically assume about their
accuracy another important part of
translating information into actions is
research this can be as straightforward
as performing the right Google search
and reading a few documents often it
involves instrumenting processes that
are already in place like logging code
or adding sensors to a production line
or conduct conducting surveys for some
applications research involves careful
design of experiments that requires
using sophisticated statistical tools to
plan what information will be gathered
how it will be gathered and how it will
be analyzed after the fact finally an
important part of data analysis is
interpretation given a large collection
of data how can we summarize it
aggregated visualize it and use
statistical summaries to go from a sea
of bits to a nugget of knowledge in
particular I want to call out the art of
visualization turning numbers into a
picture that is easily interpreted and
conveys useful information is an art as
much as a science it involves an
intuitive sense of human visual
perception and understanding
so the pillar of data modeling also has
several major subcategories this is
often referred to as machine learning
but it's no more or less than the
creating of a simplified description of
your data that you can use to make
estimates for data that you haven't
measured either something that you
didn't have a sensor for or something
that's going to happen in the future
the three main subclasses of machine
learning are supervised unsupervised and
custom model development supervised
learning uses labelled examples to
discover patterns these can be
categorical labels for example did this
customer revisit our website within the
month after making a purchase yes or no
examples can also be labeled with
numbers for example how many views did a
video receive using a large collection
of labeled examples accompanied either
by their category or value supervised
learning algorithms can distill out the
underlying patterns if the labourers
serve categorical this is called
classification and if the labels are
numerical this is called regression also
sometimes the goal is not to make a
specific prediction about future
examples but just to determine whether
they're in line with what's been seen
previously this is called anomaly
detection a second major area of machine
learning is called unsupervised learning
indicating that the data doesn't come
with labels we don't know the outcome or
the right answer but in unsupervised
learning the goal is to discover
patterns in how the data is distributed
in clustering groups of data points that
are nearer to each other than to the
rest of the data set are identified
these are the natural groupings in the
data for example this can be done to
find shoppers that buy similar items at
the grocery store in dimensionality
reduction groups of variables that tend
to behave similarly or in a coordinated
fashion are identified as well such as
the set of genes that work together to
produce a desired trait
in dimensionality reduction it's not the
data points that are being clustered but
the variables it's not the rows of the
table but the columns in apply data
modeling it's very common to have to do
custom algorithm development both
supervised and unsupervised learning
methods are general they begin by
assuming very little about the source of
the data what it means and what domain
it resides in general algorithms get
away with this by sheer statistical
power they're at their best when you
have a large collection of data however
in practical applications is often the
case that we don't have nearly as much
data as we would like and we don't have
enough to rely on naive mature machine
learning techniques when this happens we
get to do custom algorithm development
we build in the information that we know
or feel comfortable assuming about the
domain for instance one important
modeling problem in the agriculture
industry is to predict the yield for a
field of corn that's the total weight of
the harvested grain this is an
unfathomably complex system with soil
and texture chemistry genetics
temperature and moisture all interacting
and it takes a year to collect a single
data point there's no feasible way to
learn a complete crop model using lie
Eve naive machine learning methods
however geologists chemists biologists
meteorologists and geneticists have all
investigated and described the pieces of
this system and so by assembling what is
known and making some reasonable
assumptions we can create a tractable
tractable crop model moving on to data
engineering this is the third pillar of
data science it has a few major areas of
its own data management is the exercise
of storing moving and handling data it's
trivial for data sets of a few thousand
or even a few million data points but
when individual data points become very
complex like an individual's genome or
the number of data points gets into the
billions or trillions data no longer
fits inside Ram on a laptop and you have
to use an entirely new set of tools
another big task the data engineers have
is taking code that works well in
prototype and making it ready for
operation in the wider world
it is one thing to build a model in
Jupiter notebook but to be able to use
that to process and to filter every
incoming customer request the codes need
to the code needs to be made compatible
with the rest of the company's code base
and it needs to be able to ingest data
and publish results in the appropriate
formats any glitches or failures need to
be handled gracefully and the system
needs to be made secure against
mischievous or malicious users the gap
between a smoothly running prototype and
production code is a big one and part of
data engineering is the process of
closing it in both data management and
production software engineering plays an
important role that's the act of
building things out of code that not
only do what you want as fast as you
want but also can be shared and
maintained across your current team
adapted to future changes and scaled up
or down as needs evolve this is a craft
and it comes with a large collection of
tools and specialized skills there's
also a surprise pillar number for data
mechanics this is the dirty work that
everyone needs to do but nobody likes to
talk about it includes things like data
formatting making sure your types are
consistent getting information you want
out of strings making sure the strings
in use are valid handling errors
gracefully it also includes value
interpretation handling dates and times
in an interpretive interpretable and
consistent way responding correctly to
missing values making sure units of
measurement or
assistant undocumented and it includes
the fundamentals of data handling
querying slicing and joining this lets
you pull the subset of data that you
want for an operation from the great
lake of what you have available now we
have our four pillars in place data
analysis data modeling data engineering
and data mechanics what does this mean
for you as a data scientist these areas
are all very different I propose that a
data scientist is someone who has at the
very least exposure to all these skill
areas that means that you're not
necessarily an expert or even good at
them but you know what they are and you
know the right questions to ask and the
right Google searches to run a beginner
data scientist might have just a little
bit of experience in each of these
pillars with this as a base we can walk
through some data scientist archetypes
it's my hope that these will be helpful
to you in planning out your training and
career trajectory one path forward to
becoming a data science scientist is to
become a generalist to develop a solid
mixture of proficiency and analysis
modeling engineering and mechanics a
nice balance across the board gives you
a broad view of problems of varying
scopes it may mean that you'll need to
collaborate with specialists for some
projects but it sets you up very well to
be a technical leader or a data
executive just a word of caution there
may be a tendency to neglect data
mechanics or to assume that someone more
junior will take care of it the person
who does this is a data scientist diva
this is an anti-pattern this is someone
you do not want to be and you do not
want to hire mechanics can get gritty
and some days it'll occupy the majora
your time but you never outgrow the need
to do it
embrace mechanics tasks learn the skills
you need to do them adequately and get
on with it now there are three
specialist archetypes as well
emphasizing each of the three main
pillars if you choose to emphasize a -
analysis you can become a detective a
master in discovering the right data and
using it to draw conclusions a detective
is familiar with modeling and
engineering methods and uses them in a
lightweight way but analysis is their
focus another data scientist archetype
is the Oracle someone who has mastered
the skills of modeling and the tools of
machine learning they will have had
exposure to analysis and engineering but
their focus will be on modeling either
general machine learning models or
custom domain specific models finally
you can choose to emphasize data
engineering and become a maker this is a
person who helps everything work fast
and reliably their work will still
require some analysis and some modeling
and definitely some mechanics but
they'll be focused on engineering tasks
makers are the ones who transform good
ideas into concrete machinery finally
there is the unicorn this person is a
master in every pillar this is the data
science ideal except of course that it
doesn't exist becoming a master of one
pillar takes a long time becoming a
master in all three is essentially
stacking three careers on top of each
other it's not impossible to do but it's
a long road and the path down it passes
through one of the other archetypes as a
waypoint the archetypes then that are
the most useful for career planning are
the generalist detective Oracle and the
maker
another way to represent these is in a
3d plot with axes for analysis modeling
and engineering you can see the
detective Oracle and maker each lying
close to an axis the generalist is a
balance of the three sitting in the
middle of the space I want to be
completely clear that I am not implying
any hierarchy or value judgment between
the archetypes they're each invaluable
and they serve different functions let
your preferences and interests guide you
as you choose between them there's no
commonly accepted taxonomy for data
science specializations when looking for
a job
I recommend ignoring the job titles
there's no reliable way to translate
between job title and archetypal I also
recommend not worrying too much about
the specific tools listed languages
programs you ought to know instead look
at the skills implied read between the
lines to discover which archetype they
want just the posting sound more like a
maker a generalist a detective based on
this you can decide whether this
particular posting is a good match for
you also when posting a job ask for
specific skills don't ask for all of
them and don't ask for a unicorn you
won't find one what I hope you take away
from this more than anything is that you
don't have to be an expert at everything
to be a great and successful data
scientist it's enough to choose one
direction and dive in good luck if you
haven't already picked your path I hope
this helps you plan it and I wish you
lots of success along the way